we start this morning with the race to
succeed David Cameron as the
Conservative Party leader and prime
minister today the five candidates are
expected to outline more of their plans
ahead of the first ballot of Tory MPs
which will take place tomorrow the main
developments this morning and the
leadership candidate Andrea led sim will
launch her campaign as she seeks to take
on the frontrunner to resume the
Chancellor George Osborne has pledged to
cut corporation tax to cushion the
impact of leaving the EU and leave
campaigner Boris Johnson calls on the
government to deliver a detailed plan
for brexit let's go live to Westminster
now we can speak to the culture
secretary John Whittingdale who is
supporting Michael Gove very good
morning to you and first question really
why are you supporting him well I've
worked with Michael in government he's
an outstanding record as a minister he
provided extremely strong leadership
during the vote leave campaign and I
know him to be a man of principle and
conviction with experience and I think
he's the right man to take this country
forward and to negotiate our exit from
the European Union let's talk about his
principles I mean he stabbed his running
mate in the back last week the most
spectacular way just hours before he's
about to announce his own leadership
position Boris Johnson I'll go put
himself forward instead well I think
Michael reach look in conclusion having
had discussions with Boris that he
wasn't the man to provide the leadership
nurse Johnson didn't know about that
teamworks I think is a man of great
talent I I'm hugely admired his
commitment to believe cause during the
campaign and I've no doubt but he will
have a very senior role in government in
the future but at this time I think
Michael felt but having talked to him he
wasn't the man to provide the leadership
that we need now therefore I had
previously pressed Michael to put his
own name forward and so I was very
pleased when he did so he could have
chosen a better time to do it i mean
he's known Boris Johnson for 30 years
he's been campaigning to leave the
European Union for month side by side he
spent four days not airing any of his
concerns to the campaign managers Ben
Wallace who was quoted in the paper
today saying it was
late shock to them the morning that Mr
Gove decided to withdraw his support for
Boris Johnson a spectacular betrayal
well I mean I agree with you the timing
wasn't great and it would have been
better to have reached that decision
before but bear in mind firstly that
we'd spent the time campaigning to vote
for a vote to leave the European Union
I'd anything that he would have had any
conversation during the campaign about
what am daft words and indeed the one
thing all of us hoped would happen and I
signed a letter to this effect was that
the Prime Minister would continue and
therefore we wouldn't be plunged
straight into a leadership election so i
think that the subject only really arose
at the very last minute and it was as a
result of those discussions that Michael
sadly reached the conclusion that Boris
wouldn't be the man to take this country
forward the public are always already
suspicious of politicians they already
think that they can't be trusted if Mr
Gove is being seen to put self-interest
ahead of the public into the national
interest that's not going to warm him to
the public is it he's not gonna be able
to win an election as the Prime Minister
well I don't think Michael was putting
self-interest ahead in fact Michael had
said clearly that he was reluctant to
stand that he didn't have an ambition to
become Prime Minister and I think that
it was only because he reached the
conclusion that Boris was not the man to
do so and others like myself had pressed
him to stand that hit then he reached
the decision but he would do so so I
mean I think he is a reluctant prime
minister but I sure I think that's a
point in his favor if you really cared
about the national interest would it not
be better to see a coronation of Theresa
May somebody that would enable the
country to get on with the business of
working out how we're going to withdraw
from the EU rather than losing our
attention and focusing on a messy
potentially leadership battle well we
are a democracy in this country and in
the Conservative Party and actually I
think it's right and I think Teresa
herself has said so it's right that our
party members should have the ultimate
decision as to who should be leader I
don't like the idea of a coronation I
think democratic contests are a good
thing and that it will strengthen
whoever emerges as the winner in which
case would you like to see a snap
general election no we have been in this
position before John Major to go from
Margaret Thatcher Gordon Brown took him
from Tony Blair the Conservative Party
has a mature
30 in Parliament where a parliamentary
democracy as long as we have a majority
in parliament then we will continue to
govern until the next election let's
talk about what Michael Gove actually
stands for I mean if you're supporting
him do you accept being outside the
single market well these are
negotiations which haven't even started
yet I'm not frightened of being outside
the single market but what we want to do
is to have that discussion with our
friends in Europe and work out in the
arrangement well what I would like to
see is our ability to continue to trade
but at the same time we have to regain
control of our borders and stop paying
the money that we currently sent to
Europe those are two things which the
British people are very clearly voted
for and obviously we will be determined
to deliver and how do you plan to regain
control of the borders i mean the
australian style point system or it they
have a higher immigration rate than we
do here it's not going to solve the
problem well what it does mean is if we
brought in a point system is it's a much
fairer way of determining who should
come here instead of have the existing
position where anybody from any European
country can come in without our ability
to stop them which means that we've had
to put in place much stronger controls
against countries outside the european
union under a point system we judge
everybody fairly and on the basis of
what contribution they will make to our
country and when we look at the
withdrawal process is going to both
involve very delicate negotiations with
the European Union with Brussels do you
think that Michael Gove is the right
person to handle those given that if you
talk to any teacher they say that he
wasn't a good negotiation that was from
a position of power where he was able to
push through those reforms and say sorry
guys this is what we're going to do when
we're walking into the EU for those
negotiations were saying we'd really
like to try and stay in the single
market if we can but we're going to have
to lose free movement of people will he
be able to meet the right candidate for
that well I think actually Michael was
an extremely good education secretary I
think he's pretty good Justice Secretary
well he was pushing through some quite
radical reforms and there was opposition
to those but I think they were the right
reforms I think they improved our
education system as I say I know Michael
well I think he's a man of conviction
he's got great experience and obviously
the negotiations which lie ahead will be
done by a team
also have the support of the officials
in doing so will have the best and
brightest as the prime minister said and
it is in the interests of both sides
both the European Union and this country
that we reach a deal and like we've got
the first round of voting taking place
tomorrow at the moment Mr Gove isn't
looking in a particularly strong
position in fact he's losing support by
the day if he loses this leadership
election is his career finished well I
think michael has a great deal to offer
this country and I hope that you'll
continue to serve in any capacity but I
believe he's the best man to lead the
Conservative Party and to become Prime
Minister and therefore I hope that that
will be the outcome of the election and
obviously ultimately it is a decision
for the members of the Conservative
Party in the final round